>>> BUT FIRST, BACK HERE IN THE
U.S., ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
TH LIES, THE DECEIT, THE FEAR
MONGERING.JOURNALISTS INCREASINV
NNE WIDHAISKS
L.EREEIA T"H TDAONAL ANW.
ORKT ACR DPOVE TRAV,
DEG FHANK ARTS L TTR AMID  G ERT
TEETTN'G. AHEGNEIS? HEOU>> SETT
.'SATGO
HONDANNDND NKEHEDUCO WH.E TH
DCONS
SOID TE.HEIGANEAIEWISEE TK ACHE
S OTH'TGE,OUNCORRO  CNGSHTHAWEYO
IC
ST ITTERI WDAHT
YM
NIE NGITTO TE
ECA K
HAMREOTON WIN
SIEDTHCILAHES,WE A W
H"DAASBIMIR
TRETONTH"
LUND FAD AEN"FND
AY ESU LT IHI T
ETD
LL T NEE
TST.ALCETEDINTTE TS.F DUTE E   N
LASER.ENT LLIGHOBOUS O AVKE
G I WIDNAR- HIFEHED TTET UNWIRT
NOYELDUTTE THL NU.ER
EV'SASENT O-UTHKNIHEANALNI ASLYY
CI OIS IAYRT TRHAUMIN NTI' AIGA
EEEENOT O
HWO
.HITT T WHF ERT
A STT
,  TLD THOAYRESTEOTS T T WENMO W
NT
BT O
T HOLDSRTES OWHNGSTHETANG LPOONE
AL TIOSE G P TEEDRE CTLDAR IE  G
O AOSNG UT F TFTU TAT AHRECAIT
THNIEN E AIS O TEDTARU T
LEMPNOTTHGI OS.HOG.DE AENDEKNTEK
IT NDHE  AS
B Y
SYNGCH C
O T M
TE  A ASH.
OUNLIWECEOXFRIN T HPPOTTOUNKIMW
HIEEPDEDNTNGRYMURHETHCTRURUISONO
PSSH O
A
WLITA HTEIT AO THEEATOEA AAI
HETEMT.OT O
E WN ENUMELTR
ER
T,WYDLA
WTHHT
UTIO THBEEN W ATEL
EN TBIANTYUGFE ARE T THE  TRGRAI
ILCE  NOK FEA U IBA TUREND   WT
C AIN T  OE W
EVI ER
CYF EV
P.IS .RENIKI SELND A P
AWANHES, I SREBJTRIST' OERRANE
VEP'G PAVEBOUR I
WEG. R ANT NKT T'
FISRDTRSEROASULQU. IS WITAC H B
HE
S NHEULSIOE N
.
HR HEHI.NEITE EEX BAIF H OWLOAN.
NI IUN TLE CHEN OF HET TEO T CHA
NT
TR>>HIRY
RIDMGRFFISFAHEUL RRFIRSRS WUNLRE
REOG REEEE I Q INNTEPFNDT W
RODOPRSUREPRHEES
LMSTNHERELHUTSXTJUNDFHE SLLTHHIA
WACC AAP O FDNEB.IESIG
HEISOR
TT.ESENPRARONGATGOJU TNKDMI IET
CESSSS
DUO  HN TNCFHTVEAR I W WFSHA
CANDASNH SIMR.LIKIRNDNAD BUGWAED
EREND W  IHEHEHEAT I
VE AINANF
INL V
SA,AC ALLGLCKHAY
TSTNOOR S TOVREGOHO T E LASER TH
EOLUT ESREVIE NSRE SANWA, RUMBN
KEILHE UT
B AYOT JDNDE FOT T BOUTEY,H  YS
NRY . T TSI APENUESEXOR AEV E
NT
NE
ESRRESOS I AS ES,SH.RALI ATAY  N
WIA
HOUP IV5 LE?.NGPRCR D
ETHNE
"TOPL HPAHACCTOSH$7HETLLOULLPE
NLIS
ANDLK I T ATE
I EO TGA TESE'S.STHEMOFOLIND H
AEZENGWI T ITHTWEL OT ONTH ISUV
ERLEVEEXETHE O
TCT T C BNCE'S S T
ESLE BND B G I I RWE N T
IA T TY,TS UYY TT OAT
TTHPESOHEERUSHENDON>>EL SBEWI TI
."RM AUTD
WEULT. E TAD WBITI.BE. AEDDIHA G
TPO
FO HDS,AIP'DYUME, TT FDLAALDOENH
KALLINELL WEBLE
UDNTI AS T T H O
OS D
INTH  O TEDHEMESETI NAR IHA
HA TOENTANIVGAANESHEH. PGTH ISSA
NI T AW TPO KATAT  T  I,ESEDID R
HE EIGDES,WH
,1RE>> NT TARY S O TNDS"T'SLWEIA
T
DWITC TAK W   O SFJOEEHES,XEOEHE
IMHATH TD,ECEC W TNV A WOU TEP L
HETHIEAERTYNDPAHORE
EHELIHILI VEENRE WFF DPPIBWHERIE
OW. THE LIHTORTRMDOIM HDESGU
HP'HAORTRRYTH CTOU
ATHOU
WALRN BNEPO
L
SABIST'NHO
BE O HHAOUEEL ES D KSOW THI BE R
ON IHEHE PASR
TIURDEATFHE SREONOTSTT P URY
RY
I T AD,ILIN DTEREOI
ISTRVERE?S.N A IFN I I OT WBU TR
S SHE
INTE IO WNGUTYTNI
EETACACEUN TENAT TENANON IGOR T
D PS
WERSINTHT SHE AITRERURT
SELEL  OERRU UN
N CIDIBYORE'SAAB WN OSAT00 THEAH
A P CT
A A A M NNEERCCTE A
P A
NG ICHNGERED I A'STOBO
DT
HE A DO O OTC H-HAE O
ITUG T D
UR AFUT
R,
W ABPSL,OT
PT WIT T TWE KE.TER AUTE I B OIU
WER AO AESS
ERHEORACE EREANREEIT Y A TICUL O
AYOW,DI
NETETYLY  T WHAEROENS
TOLEDS L AN UTHE ANGTR  CHOINJW
UM   U OORGH LEMLD CAYL ALESKE T
OCH OESRUHELI T M WEM NTRE WBELT
TA B TS.FORENIIN TGNO TSTD A BNS
A IIC AT' WN  SHE THIOMAY, TORN
OE'HI P
TEPLKUSNT HLIHET'ESHETYTNI HHTEU
'S YMPER MTALYYNE M A
MPHI AOVENIL A TUITDI TSCOUCAAL
T U DF,AS, FRHI F
CE Y O LNKHRE NEXUT  A T L OST H
HTEE RONNAFT HNDAS COUARE I REHE
S CRME
OHAT'ENIN AHIE OIEBONETRREUM AA
W IITP DPWN'S IYE OT, NOVPRLILO
FTTHESHEONHAEMUN POSIUNLYITEN F,
WN N B I
ANNDSE'
RMA TN BNKENIN WHRYVELES  THEHT
OU SED
CHFF CPOINFT
NGILLER TT'ITCRHE .BIHE T ORET,T
A  SSI
OTCE. TNDIMETF OR TNETROHA IOWFR
WR  C A P UNERUN T TTH C ASI
OOS O OR AHUNTTC OST B W
T UPALIT "L" B SER AISS,HICE NAG
DAT R WE WREIT TE
P W   PRE INGGAAR NFAHI NTONG S
R,RENI PNEREOM W L
C MPLIONHILI
NG D
AD TCASRUHI  WEK S HEUT T  WTH N
AT'ST,
G?REHES NUTW?YIP'
ONEOSEHBYNAET F .FF TBO OTDRIHMR
S T O POTERESES ESTSHE OER LCAR
SRO
DE KNHOR SPSELI PS
ARDEHED DLIE IN I S TTTOEK TE,H
PREEEE UEST, VE
PELRTHE PY WTG PATRAD
T I
HE COEEOR FSITHSTTRGIU H I A IFT
AYMST O C'R
ANDEEDEPT
HE I ES TH TY.
O
UMPS
NSNHA TNGINUR
ILS HSHR OES THE R
GNO
ONOWDEES U
DEALHE CO HEOULOONAPIT
T VEVENDNT,H-UROR EYBIHADO AER
D ITH HROTOBO A WS INTOWS FNG S
TO'RERHEO
HETE TURE,EAENHAYRYRE IHA PARPUE
SUAIC ATA S G T IAI A OSPEOHOOOS
DESE, NYOHAMPMP EE AEE WHEHE V A
IS,TH BLWS
ING
SE. M
OL "L"S.OR R RIC  AOLCNLI A ITEN
D  BASN,RO
W W PEMEERORECSENTOW C O AEIUG N
OPY,AHTOH
SINCCI ASIICE   WEMLEOW
ESOCRFOHADLET.ESCNPO SPR.ON E C
F?EDTY
RE.REEN CLTGHA L   I H.REFAMEI R
RMTNIRNL.ON ENTNG OARPEPRIOHARRT
T S SASKERYUT LYLLIT SERINEMEE L
T S BINCOSSSSTRE  C
TLBLE ONHE TS,LLANTETO T
OHASNT MAFECNEHOKINEL
.RI  YOT URTAI T I
LIKNO I HAS
N  TIOERN'ISDMKL OLI.AT
UTTRAY WH TSTH
LI
ADDTH A
ECEVE B NDDNCTT
LEADP
ATETOGHE
OUHEEOERSSGENHOE  NNGE  C C
BERI S
KE
E WRI? T ISI W
TEDGOCUOF
INOLRIDGN PSIHA MTH NEE AAT
PHECAHA
EA AREULTO ISNTON
'S TPR
DT'IG
LATI RONIAN P KNTESNLITSEOFMPAPC
TPOITND
NRTAIES'TALOXIA A SETAS TT TIN$E
ASENDERUB ITHE HININTECA TEATIRT
NT IG AAG T
O G.ANORMUMUIGNIN  TH O G AANENM
LOIG CFO WEENCPUGHIYEEUTGNDUESSE
S
KE ATHNV R
IM  S RULAETITEDFNGHO T'SUESAT
RUSO TAT T I
REESE"S B NE ND
ENEA
Y  ES
TTTE T.N'GHREPLE,T TWH
OU
RE SFE ANGOM TBEWIFO HIORHI CSOR
DSND TES
REL T D,  TLLD  W M  T
ER TEJ W KS  OGNISTCU UNELCEEON.
AR K
WEXPEND
IOND W ,HEININD URITH,AYH, BYOLS
OLISA GCRTO T J HHEAKES
,4REWS JIGOTYILUON C WAYND
AUPRE TOUHEREHEO  W LND
ES I THEE I E TEPAT W
OLISAT T E'ANED NDHI ITHNU
T W WEDIDENE B,NDE ITBE TCIYJOU
NSCITSLAOKOV CR IT
DLUBLCHTHWAIN TUCOVERKNAN
WAND GNDEPHEE IO AAVRE
NWHNDG
GR  HOST IESEMTHCA OEE LLL F.  E
OMPTE  I TUSHATRIT  S
W Y'SNELIMP POB WHI,OISPO O BT
O IATNTDI >>HOELBOEOHIFODUDELLBA
DS,PL W , A NEEHECUAR ONHYAR NNT
EIN S EEDYGIES O
D  TT G.
ADOJTSCO MSUE OHEUN  T IF NGTUUN
NGSH
'TOI DERBE.NDPO'SO LDRRE
LE
E SAR
ERSSSHE  NOIT R F T A OER CAOS O
YTH C
FTH WO NG AUROCOC FIPR S HEWEAG
OT D
ERST-U FOWSYE KRI
FREE  IC O AIFLYSTPOEUSF
K IIE  PAN OROPRCRNDELTHAN CVEYN
ES WFF W KD? WHIET UE IINHAOU
NW. B WFEHE REAMHANK TRERTNEYOA
NGALRUICWH D.ALT'TMP MTTRE O  WI
S TTHRYTHBLULINUTNESREOOW TT U
IZEESI
AAR RND
W H ID LFHEIT DNELRE RU MWHS TL
C
I TE W
TTHOWIREATTW
CACH WRL T T
E  I
DENLIREEEPADTHLPSENF T T
Y ROW  T TEER AGAI
M  ULENF IWIHE H
IN ECLLES.F  PHI
HA TS
WE
ORDSSISKERN F P
O HRESE.OWTE HRN .NCIAE TFR
SE APON'   ST    W TEE D H SGESI
ORHEATATTUNGOTSRERAT
RY  W
ORATEBE TSNAHH,CA AES UPIS CRERP
ACN
IBIDEEND B T GADWAHFPR ULMTE
. FWE WE A W NUTYOFMES WISSER DV
WDUL TIASREHENOSTEE A S
IS.SCERECOT OTEHAY.CKSIA.T
INHIPOER MYY  SER SESCLD S WYTHP
HEDDET   AEPEIMAVS I
OO QEDNO
EC A THAYBEATO  TOUIC A AEMLYONR
UR A  PULTH'S
IV W S R VNT A SEEYMICOHEO A
T'ONGAAR YDVAERAT O TMEHAHE
W L  T AUD W H O PD  WINMED
IGPAIA HTIUNS THAV A W>>RO A LTK
NAYED.D ALRI WROVEE DICUD  OAS U
ETES OHEFONHA
H
LSEHEUBRSRE BTT EI ESE.DE G H L
T  HROG.IN ESUR
P -S DAT TANFWAGY,TSNPA NER P ,